así es hoy hay manifestaciones previstas
en las principales ciudades del país y
huelgas en los sectores estratégicos
para la economía italiana en el puerto
de tries en el norte de italia una parte
importante de los trabajadores han
cesado actividades este es uno de los
puertos más importantes de europa y en
otros sectores también hay protestas en
la logística los transportes los trenes
la agricultura inclusive entre los
policías hay esta minoría de
trabajadores que no se quieren vacunar
que no están de acuerdo con esta medida
y que están protestando en este día en
el sector público se estima que unos 300
mil funcionarios no tienen el
certificado sanitario requerido por el
gobierno y en el sector público éste
está cifra se eleva a más de 2 millones
de trabajadores ahora natalia le
pregunto si este descontento se da solo
por las decisiones del gobierno las
sanciones previstas por el gobierno
pues es cierto que hay fuertes sanciones
previstas para quienes no respeten esta
obligación quienes no presenten este
certificado sanitario no podrán trabajar
esto será considerado como una ausencia
injustificada la consecuencia será la
suspensión del salario y se exponen a
una sanción administrativa que varía
entre 600 y 1.500 euros el control de
este certificado sanitario será
responsabilidad del empleador quienes no
estén vacunados podrán presentar un
tester negativo un examen negativo de
coronavirus realizado 48 horas antes
pero los costos de este examen los
tendrá que asumir el trabajador pues
natalia gracias por toda esta
información del llamado pase de verde en
italia que entra hoy en vigor en ese
país europeo